[Music]
Khloe Kardashian is expecting her first
child with boyfriend Tristan Thompson
you're lying
and the reality star is slaying the
maternity wear game one sexy outfit at a
time thank you I feel great and I feel
so lucky to feel so great the mama-to-be
shared this sultry pic on Instagram
posing in nothing but black lacy
lingerie and a silky robe as she held
her baby bump
Chloe worked it in a pair of her good
American jeans with a white long-sleeved
crop top and dazzled in this bodysuit
that showed just a hint of skin oh the
33 year old looked old Hollywood glam in
navy for a stop by Jimmy Kimmel Live
Koko worked the cameras in a white
leotard sans pants looked hotter than
ever in this ruched little black dress
and cradled her tummy in a nude
form-fitting number oh my god with like
five exclamation points
Chloe was pretty in pink during a
vacation to Japan and rocked a lacy slip
for her over-the-top baby shower it was
fun but only a Kardashian could make
posing topless in elastic waist denim
look so good
you
[Music]